I want to jump to uh this story here we
have this uh clip from The Joe Rogan
Experience Jack besobic says breaking
Joe Rogan says there was real fraud in
the Cary Lake election the context
Beyond this is a story from the Daily
Mail that finds 69 of Republicans
believe that Biden uh his win was
illegitimate and that there was
widespread fraud but let's play this
clip first we got Patrick Bet David he
rocks and Joe Rogan also very great
how much election fraud do you think is
real here we go Joe you want to go to
election fraud yeah because I don't
think it's zero no it's not zero I think
we could all agree it's not no way it's
not zero and we know that these voting
machines can be with yeah and we
know that there's some irregularities uh
all that that carry Lake stuff in
Arizona that they're trying to dismiss
it doesn't look like that's invalid it
looks like there's real fraud there it
looks like there's some real Shenanigans
there at the very least there was voting
machines that weren't working properly
and it seems very suspicious that a lot
of them were in Republican areas there's
a lot of shenanigans there's a and I
think there's coordinated efforts to
make sure that certain people get
elected I don't know how far they go but
I know it's not zero he's right it is
not zero even Bill Barr said it wasn't
zero and that's the big question 69
percent of Republicans think there was
widespread fraud and Biden did not win
so uh there was a tweet it was Robbie
Starbuck put out a poll saying do you
think we're in a civil war and uh of
course you all know how I voted in that
poll but uh the overwhelming majority of
people said yes there were four choices
one was nowhere not and then one was not
yet but soon and that was the second
most voted position
so
here's the way I'll frame it
and I guess I've said this before it all
depends on where we go next
if Donald Trump is clear of all charges
scotus says these charges are are
politicking and weaponizing the justice
department
Trump ends up winning Trump fires a
handful of people there are some reforms
it's a little a little tumultuous but
mostly we just we move past it no one
will ever talk about this as a civil war
or revolution or conflict they'll just
say you know there was a rough patch
if it does escalate
Beyond where we are now
not just today but probably January 6
probably 2016 will be considered the
second Civil War period
so 50 100 years from now if whatever is
happening now does break out into hot
conflict or totally totalitarianism or
something they'll write the conflict all
started in 2015 when when the Clinton
campaign falsely accused her Chief rival
of being a spy working for this right
for the Russian government and that
kicked off a chain of events which
resulted in impeachments Street battles
I think for sure it'll go back to
September 11th in The Patriot Act if if
it gets to like this is the time of
History where the United States ended it
will be remembered that that stupid bill
that let you put throw people in jail
with no cause but that's that that's
that's where it all began they won't say
that that's reductive they better when
you look at when we look at the the
Civil War period you could bring up
Bleeding Kansas but nobody considers
that the Civil War they consider it like
a component of pre-civil war and then if
you go back a couple decades to like um
what was I think the 1850s the the uh
what was it the catching slaves act or
whatever was a big Catalyst because
the bill was basically if slaves escaped
to the South to the north the north
would have to return the fugitives and
the north said you got it the bill was
passed and then the north said yeah
right we're not doing that so the South
was basically saying if the federal
government passes laws the north will
not adhere to what is the point of a
federal government it does nothing yep
we don't we don't go back and say it all
started here with the Fugitive Slave Act
no we say it was a component and people
will consider 911 as component but the
Civil War period I believe likely it
theoretically has a bunch of components
that lead into with like Occupy Wall
Street the Great Recession Afghanistan
and Iraq I mean demoralizing
destabilizing for the United States it
bankrupted our country the shift was
2015. I wouldn't Define a civil war
unless there was unless there was
when I say violence I guess I don't mean
just black lives matter violence or
antifa violence I would call it like if
there's conflict violence like a hot War
I would describe what we're in right now
as a cultural revolution which can be a
precursor to a hot War it can be a
precursor to a Civil War I voted in that
poll too and I voted not yet but soon
kind of like TBD dot dot dot cultural
revolution just means one side's not
fighting back that's exactly what's
happening yeah I mean because you know
whenever people say we're not in a civil
war because there's no hot conflict yet
I'll just say Aaron Danielson was shot
twice in the chest by a guy with a
Marxist tattoo with a BLM tattoo on his
neck yeah you're just not paying
attention to it there's been a ton of
violence the the BLM riots was a major
component of whatever this cultural
Civil War or or uh cultural revolution
is and yeah perhaps it is just a
revolution a communist I like that
cultural revolution that's what I think
is happening it's the same thing The Mao
did it's in the 50s it's the same thing
the whole dividing people into the left
and the right is that what Mao did to
create a cultural revolution so that
then you can pull the tail on one of the
dogs and they start chasing each other
and you're the crazy monkey that gets to
watch this is what the first half of my
book is about so like I when we see all
these crazy things like we just
described as like oh our culture's in
chaos or we're watching critical race
Theory and trans ideology being
indoctrinated into our kids and I'm like
okay why is this all happening at the
same time I mean I know that Republicans
don't fight back so maybe they just
thought it was an easy in but this seems
like a concern yeah yeah how did we get
here and it turns out as I looked into
this the answer to that is less of a why
and more of a who as I researched it I
found the people in the organizations
behind each of the attacks on all these
cultural institutions and they are
invariably marxists I mean even the
black lives matter movement that you
just mentioned I mean this is the
obvious one people are familiar with
this but the founders of the black lives
matter movement are openly marxists they
brag about being trained marxists you
see all these books I mean I see you
have genderqueer sitting here on the
table I mean the president of the
American Library Association is a
self-avowed Marxist these people are
actual Communists actual marxists and
they are using the destabilization of
our cultural institutions the Civil
institutions to get us to economic
destabilization so that they can topple
our government that is the definition of
a cultural revolution people are just
like whoa communist Marxist like it's
just Republican versus Democrat and if
you actually peel back the layers and
look at who's behind this it's not a
coincidence it's not chaos it's actual
Marxism
embraced Marxism
I think that they are ideological
marxists I think Marxism is is economic
we think of it economically when we
think of Karl Marx in The Communist
Manifesto we think of the uh working
class overthrowing the ruling class and
I think that that didn't really work it
didn't they didn't it never caught on to
become a global Revolution that they
wanted so it sort of died out but then
Antonio gromsey who was this uh Italian
Marxist founder of the Italian Communist
party or co-founder said well listen if
You observe the cultural revolutions
that were successful or these Marxist
revolutions they started culturally
first you overtake the Civil
institutions that the working class rely
on to destabilize society and then
they're willing to actually revolt
against the ruling class like the root
of all of this is economically they're
anti-capitalist and then many I mean
many if you if you analyze the Marxist
or the Communist ideology there's a
spiritual aspect of it too I mean the
United States is being targeted because
we are fundamentally a Christian Nation
built on Christian morals built on
judeo-christian morals and marxists
can't stand that can you the difference
between communism and Marxism
yeah it's essentially uh this the same
thing it's just a specific version of it
so communism is this false idea that
there can be Collective ownership of
everything that there is there's no
private property there's no one person
in charge it's just everybody owns
everything Marxism is uh the tool to
achieve that so Marxism pits one class
against another one saying that you know
the working class is oppressed they are
oppressed by the ruling class and in
order to achieve communism Marxism is
the Revolutionary tactic that's why it's
important I think to differentiate
between communism and the marxists that
are behind the cultural revolution here
because they are trying to destabilize
our society using that tactic to achieve
communism so there could be other
tactics to achieve communism than
Marxism including perhaps economic
um technocracy something where we're all
the same in a machine yeah technography
is so that's actually really interesting
I have a whole chapter in my book about
technocracy because technocracy is ruled
by the experts right like you you can't
you can't question fauci because fauci
is technocrat the root of technocracy
can be traced all the way back to French
socialists and Russian marxists who are
part of the Bolshevik Revolution there
was a a Russian Marxist who actually
described technocracy as a stepping
stone from capitalism to communism
because this was always the problem for
Communists and Marxist right people
aren't just going to be wake up one day
and be like oh cool we live in a free
Society yes I'd love to have communism
there has to be some frog in a pot of
boiling water moment in a culture where
people are slowly introduced you know
incrementally into communism technocracy
is a stepping stone for that that's why
we see it with the administrative State
we see it with fauci we see it with like
once you have kids you see this all the
time in like the pediatrician industry
you as a parent aren't allowed to
question anything anything from
breastfeeding to co-sleeping to vaccines
you have to defer to The Experts it's
everywhere and it's conditioning people
not to question not to dissent just to
obey which is the Communist way are
there historically uh examples of
Nations or people going towards that
communist route and then stopping and
saying Hell No realizing what's
happening and Civil Wars break out has
it ever been a peaceful
um regurgitation I I think it's probably
hard to cite examples because it
wouldn't be documented as a significant
moment if it just reversed itself and
never really went that way it's a good
question though because it's kind of a
chilling question if you think about it
if we can't sit here and name a cultural
revolution that had it or that was
trying to transform a free Society to a
communist Society it means that often it
wasn't stopped it either wasn't
significant enough or it wasn't stopped
because the examples that I can think of
are examples that took a relatively free
or relatively religious society and
turned it into oppression tyranny and
death there's the inverse there's Spain
the Communists and the and the
Republicans or the nationalists were
fighting and then it was the right that
won that one and same in in Germany the
Nazis destroying the Communists the
Nazis I mean one of the principal
components of the propaganda was to
fight communism
yeah the Bolsheviks yep
I I
believe there's a way to do it
peacefully with this technology but I
mean it's owned by the technocrats so I
don't know how that works I'd like to
say what I think online guys
sorry that goes back to what I was
saying before about like the augmented
reality that's why I I don't consider
myself a cynic I do consider myself a
skeptic because I don't trust these
people I don't trust the like AI people
always talk about AI being this like
sentient being this like this this thing
that can take over and think for itself
and I'm like no somebody is behind
writing the algorithms of all of those
things and that somebody is someone
whose ideology is very different than
ours who wants to use that to influence
the way that we or our children or
whoever think so that they can convince
those people to act in certain ways that
benefit their political ideology thanks
for watching this clip from the timcast
IRL podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8 pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time